hello everybody markiplier here I just
wanted to make another video because in
the midst of all the fields that were
going on in the past video it may have
gotten buried but we are doing another
free giveaway I'm giving away ten ten of
my new markiplier t-shirts which you can
see in the market Flyers shop
markiplier swag shop down in the
description below I did open a t-shirt
store so you can you guys have been
asking for a while so I did open a
t-shirt store there's two designs the
first one is the markiplier design same
as my minecraft one with the big red
Luminess and em and markiplier written
underneath it the second one is a chair
which says stay calm and always carry a
chair good like good good lesson to live
by
but the giveaway is all you'll need to
do this is kind of similar to the last
giveaway I did but more controlled I
want there only to be one entry per
person to give a more reasonable chance
to win for everybody and so that people
can't just spam share and you know spam
and other stuff like that and I don't
want this to be sort of like I'm just
you know a ploy to get shares I really
am giving away because I love you guys
and you guys are the best fans in the
world and you deserve to get something
rewarded for your loyalty so what you'll
need to do is pick any one of my
reaction compilations pick any reaction
compilation my slender reaction
compilation amnesia any of them and
share it on Facebook Twitter either one
doesn't matter whatever you think will
have the most impact and once you do
take a screenshot of it by clicking by
pressing your Print Screen button pretty
I'm pretty sure that almost every single
keyboard has a print screen button open
mspaint or whatever the same Mac one is
copy paste and send it to me at this
email I'm gonna write it like magic
appear across the screen here alright
may not be magic like that but it's
written there it's in the description
below
markiplier at gmail that come make sure
I get it put your name in I will take
care of everything I'll get it shipped
out to you you beautiful individual out
there
and we'll get in contact later and one
week from today one week from today
that's Thursday of next week I will do
the drawing on video right here I'll do
another via log with the drawing and we
will get you your free t-shirts and if
you don't feel like you there are also
hood hoodies hooded sweatshirts down in
the shop as well so please take a look
at the shop in the description below
please share a video send me when you do
share and hopefully you will win a free
t-shirt I'm hoping that at Comic Con
next year I just see a sea of people
wearing black t-shirts with big red M's
on them so thanks again everybody you've
done so much for me and I can't help but
be grateful every day that I get to do
this so thank you so much thanks for the
video thanks for everything and thanks
for watching so man just thanks for
everything really I'm so excited moving
into the future it's gonna be a great
great year I can already tell I mean
this year is almost over
well not even close to almost over but
next year is gonna be great year next
year even better the future is looking
very bright so thank you all so much and
as always I will see you in the next
video